apparently the biden administration
facing mounting pressure over its border
border policies including a new plan to
pay out
to illegal immigrants the proposed plan
would reportedly send 450 million tax
that's wrong it should say 450 000
taxpayer dollars per person to families
who were separated at our southern
border here to react house judiciary
committee member and author of the
upcoming book do what you said you would
do fighting for freedom in the swamp
congressman jim jordan jim good morning
to you
good to be with you steve okay so the
wall street journal broke this story
that apparently the administration
considering essentially paying at at
least a million dollars per family to
these migrant families who were impacted
by president trump's zero tolerance
policy at the southern border where when
a family unit was uh was taken into
custody you can't keep the kids with the
adults so they put them in separate
places and some of them got separated
permanently
yeah no i mean and think about this
you're gonna you're gonna pay people
half a million dollars who broke the law
at the same time the biden
administration is getting ready to raise
taxes on the hard-working families of
this country it makes absolutely no
sense and it and you know i i think
about this first you break the law you
get amnesty with democrats now they're
going to pay you for breaking the law i
mean you you think we have a problem in
a caravan coming towards towards the
border now and what we've seen over the
last several months
wait until the word gets out that you
actually get paid for breaking the law
to come into our country
one of the many stupid policies from
this administration sure when the word
goes out not only
you know is joe biden saying come on
or rather officially don't come but come
on yeah and your family will get a
million dollars if you were involved in
this that that's going to be crazy but i
i have a question for you jim um
apparently according to the wall street
journal the there's like a dozen uh big
law firms who are negotiating with the
government on behalf of these migrant
families yeah how much do you think
those lawyers are going to get if if the
average family gets a million bucks the
lawyers are going to get at least half
of it
yeah they always get a big take and and
again
so the american taxpayers their taxes
are getting ready to go up let's hope it
doesn't happen let's hope they don't
pass this crazy package but that's what
democrats want to do raise your taxes
meanwhile pay law law firms a bunch of
money for people who broke the law to
get here it makes absolutely no sense
and that's on top of what we've seen
remember every single month for six
months in a row the illegal encounters
on the border went up march was the
highest on record until april april was
the highest till may may was the highest
till june june was the highest till july
when 212 000 illegals came across our
border right this is the situation and
all now we're gonna give you money if
you do it makes no sense meanwhile let's
talk a little bit about the governor's
race in the commonwealth of virginia
where right now according to the polls
fox news poll glenn younkin is way ahead
of terry mcauliffe with less than a week
to go
we had the story out yesterday that
apparently terry mcauliffe here in the
11th hour paid a a lawyer by the name of
mark elias he used to be with perkin
cooy
which has been aligned as they're the
people uh who were involved in the the
steele dossier and hillary clinton and
all that stuff anyway they hired him for
about 60 000 on the mcauliffe side so
fox news reaches out for a comment and i
guess the mcauliffe campaign person hit
the wrong button and instead of
responding they said can we try to kill
this which apparently yeah they did they
didn't want that story out there
yeah they didn't want the american
people to know they hired this dirty
trickster lawyer for the democrats who
happened to have been the partner of the
guy john durham just indicted michael
zussman these were the guys that perkins
cooey who put helped put together the
whole plan when they did the fake
dossier and went after president trump's
campaign so uh i can see why they didn't
want the story out there but it
shouldn't surprise us it shouldn't
surprise terry mcauliffe's been you know
i think his name is terry mcauliffe
clinton he's been he's been associated
with the clintons forever so it
shouldn't surprise us he's using their
lawyer to try to play the same kind of
games and go after uh glenn yonkin uh
jim
15 second answer
why is glenn young can win it
yeah cause moms and dads actually know
more about their kids education the guy
this idea that government knows more
than a parent than a mom or a dad that
that that offends people well it should
and they've said enough of this baloney
we're going to put someone in office who
actually respects us as parents and
families all right congressman jim
jordan thank you sir for joining us live
you bet thank you and that sound bite
was exactly 15 seconds just saying
excellent job thank you